police in Phoenix say they've identified
a suspected serial killer responsible
for a string of murders 35 year-old
cleofas Cooksey junior was already in
custody he is accused of killing nine
people during a three week period late
last year Carter Evans is in Phoenix
with how technology helps sell of the
case Carter good morning good morning
Cleophus Cooksey spent 16 years in
prison for manslaughter and armed
robbery
now he'd only been out for about 18
months when police arrested him again
this time it was for the murder of his
mother and stepfather while he was in
custody police linked in to seven other
killings we can sleep a little better
tonight knowing that his killer is
caught anthea wint says the first time
she heard the name Cleophus Cooksey jr.
was thursday morning when police told
her he was responsible for her son's
murder 29 year-old Latorre Beckford was
shot twice near an apartment building in
Glendale Arizona on December 13th
Khloe ridore a is his younger sister but
it was an innocent bystander and it it's
sad that it was him cook sees scene in
this YouTube video rapping about murder
is accused of killing seven men and two
women in the Phoenix area from November
27th to December 17th all died from
gunshot wounds Phoenix police credit
advanced ballistic technology with
helping link Cooksey to the murders
Phoenix is one of five cities that
joined a national program allowing
agencies to rapidly share analyze and
process evidence from different crime
scenes we solved nine homicides in three
weeks
I think that's astounding for any Police
Department Jonathan Howard is with the
Phoenix Police Department's do you think
you might link this suspect to other
crimes
I think there is a possibility in fact
I'm gonna say I think there's a
probability that there are additional
homicide
they're involving this same suspect
anthea wind says while Thursday's arrest
gives her closure
it still doesn't bring her son back he
had the willful life
and I cannot imagine that he's not here
anymore each and every day is very hard
police say they're still trying to
determine Cooke C's relationship with
each of the victims and a motive for the
killings we have contacted his lawyer
but have not heard back
gale he is being held right now on a 5
million dollar bond all right thank you
very much Carter